يدخل العالم ثوره علميه جديده عنوانها
عضلات صناعيه تفوق قوه العضلات البشريه
بسبعه عشره مرات هذا ثوره قدها علماء
كوريون نجحوا في تطوير هذه العضلات
باستخدام الياف المصنوعه من ماده جديده
لتكون الاختراق الابرز في عالم القوات
الصناعيه الممثله للبشر
التوقعاته الاوليه لهذا الانجاز تذهب
الامكانيه استخدام هذه العضلات في مختلف
الصناعات لاسيه مربوطات واعضاء الجسم
الداخليه للصناعيه حيث يتوقع ان تحل مكان
الاجهزه الميكانيكيه لروبوتات والتي ترجع
الحركه الجسم غير طبيعيه وغير مماثله لجسم
الانسان
[موسيقى]
اذا النجاح الكوري بتصميم وتطوير هذه
العضلات الصناعيه ياتي بنقاط عده فالعلماء
الكوريون صور والعضلات باستخدام الياف
مركبه تجمع الغرافين مع ماده كريستال سائل
من النوع الهلام هذه الماده سمحات للعضلات
المخترعه بان تتقلص وتصرخي مثل العضلات
البشريه مع التغيرات في درجات الحراره دون
الحاجه لطاقه اخرى
جدا من النسيج العضلات الصناعيه يبلغ سمك
شعر الانسان رفع الثقل بوزن كيلوغرام واحد
حركات والعضلات الصناعيه الجديده تاتي من
تقلص البنيه الجزيئيه المرتبه في صفا بشكل
غير منتظم عند تعرضها للضوء الحراره
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من القاهره محمد جاويش المتخصص
في تطبيق الروبوتات اهلا بك يا محمد يعني
عضلات اصطناعيه اقوى 17 مره من العضلات
البشريه نتحدث اكثر عن بنيه هذه العضلات
وطبيعه عملها ومقارنتها بالعضله البشريه
بشكل كبير قوي المجال ده بشكل عام بيعتمد
على الاطراف التعويضيه بشكل كبير وازاي
نعرف نستخدم
[موسيقى]
التكنولوجي ان احنا بنحاول نعتمد على
سينسورز وحساسات موجوده عشان تحس بالنضات
وبعد كده نقدر نحرك بها الاجزاء
الميكانيكيه وفي نفس الوقت بيكون فيه
كنترول يونتس دي بتبقى وحده برمائيه
الخاصه بالتحكم بالعضلات دي معظم الاوقات
كانت بتبقى عباره عن اجزاء زي مواتير او
اجزاء حركيه بتعتمد على الكهرباء المميز
جدا في الابتكار ده اللي هي بقت بتعتمد
على الحراره وفي نفس الوقت هي عباره عن
الياف والالياف دي نقدر نجمع منها الالياف
اكبر كثير تحاكي عمل العضلات الحقيقيه
هذا بالنسبه للروبوتات والاعضاء الصناعيه
هل يمكن ان نذهب ابعد من ذلك بكثير ان
نطور هذه التقنيه في عضله في الجسم عضله
حيه لكي تكون ب 17 مره اقوى من العضله
الاصليه
ده حقيقي دائما لما احنا بنحاول نطور
التكنولوجيا بتاعه الاجزاء التعويضيه كنا
بنحاول في الاول خالص ان احنا نحاول
نعملها بالشكل الطبيعي او بشكل التقليدي
بنفس القوه البشريه لكن بدون ان احنا
عندنا القدره استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي ان
احنا نعمل سيناريشن نعمل محاكاه نقدر نوصل
لاضاف اضعاف القوه دي لان انا فعلا ان
احنا نستخدم اكثر من مجموعه من الالياف
المختلفه بحيث ان احنا نوصل لدرجه زي 10
اضعاف و17 ضعف من القوه الطبيعيه وده
موجود كمان في التكنولوجيا الهكسوس كلتون
اللي احنا بنحاول نعمل اجزاء كمان خارجيه
مش داخليه بس الجسم الانسان بحيث انها
تساعده انه نعرف يحمل الاوزان كبيره جدا
ما كانش يقدر يحملها في الشكل العادي
بتاعه محمد ده متخصص في تطبيق الروبوت هل
يفهم من ان هذه العضله في حركه داخل جسم
الانسان ستكون اكثر مرونه واكثر واكثر
طبيعيه مع حركه الجسم مقارنه بالعضلات
الروبوتيه الميكانيكيه
طبعا طبعا مشاكل كبير جدا بسبب ان هي
دلوقتي ما بتعتمدش على بتريز ما بتعملش
على كهرباء هي بتعتمد على درجه الحراره بس
فيحصل قدر يحصل لها انتجريشن او دمج داخل
جسم الانسان بشكل اسهل بكثير جدا عن شكل
الاولي للكهرباء او للمواتير وفي نفس
الوقت باستخدام حاجه زي دي تقدر في ناس
تبقى عضويه نعرف نحطها جوه العضو من غير
ما تاثر عليه ما يبقاش فيه اي تشويش اي
الكترونكس او اي باور بياثر على جسم
الانسان فاستخدام ابتكار زي اللي بتتكرار
العظيم ده ان احنا نعرف نستخدم درجه
الحراره دي هتفرق كثير جدا وفي نفس الوقت
بما انها الياف والالياف الدقيقه جدا
استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي والسميريشن نقدر
ان احنا نعلي من قدرتها وكفيتها بشكل كبير
طيب خلينا نتخيل للمستقبل لمحمد في حال تم
فعلا توظيف هذه التقنيه وتطوير العضلات
لكي تكون بهذه القوه كيف سنتخيل شكل
المستقبل بالنسبه بقى للانسان الذي يحتاج
لعضلات جديده وحتى لو روبوتات
والله شكل المستقبل بالنسبه للانسان
الانسان دائما هيبقى انتجتد بالماشينز او
انتجريتد بالتكنولوجي الانسان حاليا ممكن
يكون هو بيستخدم العضله دي عشان هو بيفقد
عضله فدي هتفرق معه جدا في حياته وهتعوضه
عن الحياه الطبيعيه بتاعته يعرف يستخدمها
بشكل طبيعي سواء كانت يد سواء كانت رجل
وفي نفس الوقت الانسان الطبيعي خالص بعد
كده يقدر يبقى عنده اطراف زياده يضرب عنده
ذراع ثالث او يقدر يبقى عنده اصابع اكثر
عشان يعرف ينجز اعماله بشكل اقوى وبشكل
اسرع وشكل ادق جديد بنسبه كبيره قوي كل
التوقعات في مجال الروبوتكس الجديد في
اضافه البروستاتكس او اضافه البيونك
انجيلنج ازاي نعرف نضيف للانسان ادوات
اكثر تبقى اكثر كفاءه واكتر انتاجيه
شكرا جزيلا لك ههه